alhamd
[Silence]
we had left off in our previous
session
discussing what the prophet
s. would say between his
two between the two s we mentioned the
narration
of that he would say and he would say
it over and over and we also mention the
narration of I
and there are other wordings as well
we've often
mentioned that a very good
book to refer to with regards
to what a person should say when and the
narrations and the the supplications of
the prophet sallallah alaihi wasallam
and thear of the Prophet s. wasam and
the an of the Prophet sallallah alaih
wasallam at different venues
different instances different times a
very good book for that and a very
concise book is Muslim it's in wide
circulation it is abundantly available
and
accessible and Muslim Fortress of a
Muslim is a is a very good book it
has been critiqued by some as having
some weak narrations this is is an issue
of opinion and it's an issue of
itad and so while some
Scholars May view that there are weak
narrations in it others will view that
those narrations are not in fact
weak this is a very very good book to
refer to and a person should memorize of
this book as much as he or she is able
to moving on
discussing the prophet
s.'s
following meaning we discussed what he
would do from the beginning of
Salah all through the first and then
back to the standing position again for
the second or the subse
subsequent what would he do
well he says here
that he the prophet Sall wasam would
continue on with the remainder units of
prayer and
subsequent in his prayer just as he had
performed the first ra so exactly as he
performed the first he would per form
the second and third and
fourth he said except for four things
four things are different and unique to
the first ra number one a which means
that he would be silent between the the
initiating and reciting the Quran
that is only for the first ra and we
discuss that the second
is these supplications or the Dua
that is made after the
first and at the beginning
of this is something which is particular
and unique to the
first
likewise third thing is the
initiating we don't have that that is
only in the
first and the fourth and final
difference would be
which is the length we said that the
order of the Prophet Sall alam's prayer
would be longest to shortest so all of
the the first RA in any prayer is the
longest and then each subsequent units
of prayer would become incrementally
shorter he says now with regards to
T which is what occurs in the second
or the fourth or the third right for or
depending in the night prayer it depends
on on what kind of prayer he is
making he
says he says and if the prophet Sall Al
wasam would sit
for he would place his left hand over
his left
thigh and he would likewise place his
right hand on his right
thigh I believe I have a misprint
here and he would gesture with his
index finger of his right hand straight
and we've described this
before and he would neither make it
high up right so is it it is as it is
pointing to the sky nor would he make
it going down it would be just in the
middle almost pointing and some Scholars
have mentioned pointing towards the
yes he
says so he would neither erect it and
point Towards the Sky with it nor would
he have it flat down right as if he is
praying with it pointing towards the
ground rather it would be
straight yeah
rather he would
slightly slightly bend it right and he
would move it just I'm doing right
here this is what is
describing and he would CLP both his
pinky and ring
fingers right this
and he would make a circle form a circle
with his middle finger and his thumb
while clasping these two fingers which
are the pinky and the ring finger right
and then he would move his finger in
this way that I am describing to you
exactly right
now and he would do it just as I'm doing
it this is what is is intending by what
he's saying right and he would move it
ever so slightly as he is making Dua so
kind of emphasis when you're making
Dua with your hands right this emphasis
that you move your hands and say please
please same thing here with the with the
finger
and he would stare at it he would look
at his finger in this position the
scholars differ on many of these
details however the issue is is that
where should a person look during prayer
this is an issue that has been discussed
and debated
amongst Scholars of both of both ancient
and and contemporary
times where should a person's Vision be
focused when he or she is in
prayer and the correct
opinion is that while a person is in the
standing position if he is the Imam he
should look to his place of sujud or if
he's playing praying alone if he is
praying behind an Imam then it should be
between his place of suu
and the IM person should look at the IM
when the IM moves when the IM makes Etc
because the person if he can see the
Imam he needs to see what the Imam is
doing if a person is in rur it would
just be wherever his vision naturally
Falls in rur others mention like
I that it should be perhaps between his
two feet or straight to the ground when
a person is in sudu his eyes are open
they are exactly where they can only
look they only have one choice of
Direction and that is the place of suud
and in the sitting position in t that a
person be looking at his or her finger
right while they are in Salah doesn't
mean that the head needs to bend right
sometimes we see people exaggerate
they're trying to follow the Sunnah and
so they do things that they do not
are not aware of that they are doing so
they will bend their head or they will
look this the the head is straight
the face is towards the and his out of
the corner of his eye he is looking at
his index finger
in and so the prophet
alai wasam would extend his left hand
over his left
thigh and he would also lean and put his
weight onto his left arm and his left
thigh and as for how he would sit for
his and here is speaking about the first
so this is
for or any
regular optional prayers or as
well he is speaking about the first T of
any prayer that has more than one t so
he would have his left arm this and
he's leaning on it his weight is resting
onto his left arm his right finger and
hand is as we've described and he's
sitting with his left foot underneath
his buto and his his weight is on
that and then he's got his right foot
perched up with the toes towards
the he
says for
[Silence]
and so there is a narration on the
authority of
Zu Zu abdah Zu he was born in the time
of the Prophet sallai
wasallam however he was a young boy
when the Prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam passed away but his
narrations are considered to be
narrations that are accepted as long
as the chain of narration leading to him
is authentic then it is considered to be
a narration which is authentic and the
reason for this is that he would have
only heard these narrations from his
father or anybody else his
father or others of the companions of
the Prophet sallallah alai wasallam this
narration is collected by IM Muslim
which states that if the prophet
sallam would sit for Salah he would
place his left
foot
between his right thigh and right
shank the thigh and shank of his right
foot that's the this is the right thigh
he would place his foot underneath like
this and he would be sitting on the
ground this is how Zu described
this he says this is not for regular
this is for the
last so the
third of the fourth
of and this is what is known
as amongst the scholars of and and this
is one of the types
of is a very specific way that the
prophet
Sall was narrated to have sat in the
final
T in the final
T so we have in the
first
and because it only has
one we mentioned the way that he would
sit now in the second Tah
which would be the final
in he would often do something called
A and A is a different position that he
would sit in this is something which is
not obligatory this is something which
is of the Sunnah of the prophet
sallallahu alaih wasallam and the
various types of are all mentioned in
the six books of Hadith meaning not
every type is in every one of the six
books meaning Collective
those three types so we have the first
and most common type of is that he
sallallahu alaih wasallam would
sit and his left foot would go out under
the shin of his right foot of his right
leg and his right leg would be up and it
would be coming out this protruding
from the side and his leg is going over
this and he would be resting
sitting on the ground that is one type
of another type of that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam was narrated
to have done is that both of his feet
would be out towards the right and he
would be sitting on the floor his right
leg would be over his left foot and his
right foot would be coming out like
this now a third is what was just
mentioned here by on the authority of I
Zu and that is that he would sit with
his right foot jutting out and his left
foot between the thigh and shin of his
right leg and his weight would be on the
ground and his butt o would be flat on
the ground he would be sitting on the
ground these are three types
of now the point of a is that it is
to
distinguish between the
first and second T right especially for
those who are praying behind the Imam
that they can come and they can see that
the Imam is in the first or the final
T now this is something that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam would do and
a person is encouraged to do it even on
his own as long as it will not as
long as it will not interfere with his
neighbors in the in prayer so while a
person is is in the
row in Salah normal Salah now we have
special circumstances obviously with
with covid but inshallah when things go
back to normal and people start to pray
shoulder toosh shoulder
again it is not correct for a person to
make and place all of his because the
weight will shift once you have both of
your feet and legs out to the right your
weight is going to shift to the left and
if if you're praying next to someone
close you're going to end up essentially
placing all of your weight on that
person that's extremely annoying
extremely rude person is not to do that
in
prayer the prophet s. wasam mentions
in a
sun on the authority
that the best of you in prayer
is that the best of you in prayer is the
one who has the softest shoulders and
the scholars mention what does that mean
the softest shoulders and one of the
meanings of that is that he is not
rigid in his position to where he will
put in a position of discomfort
comfort those who are praying on either
side of him rather he will mold himself
to the to the row that he is praying
in so sometimes people they are
enthusiastic to follow the Sunnah but
if we don't have all of the knowledge we
just have some of it and we try to
practice only some of it we end up
neither practicing the Sunnah nor
practicing anything else so it's
important that we have all of the Sunnah
anything that we learn we learn it
entirely so that when we do it we know
that we're doing it correctly part
knowledge or half of knowledge is is is
very dangerous at
times he he
says he goes on to say
[Silence]
he said and the prophet
s would always make t in this position
meaning in the first you make this T and
in the second tah you as well make this
Tah
with and the wording of that
is and in another
wording both are correct
now a person may hear this and think
that well wait a minute that's a little
bit different in its wording than what I
was taught there are a number of
wordings of T just as there are a number
of wordings
of
so there are a number of ways to make
a and the different various wordings are
found in bukari and Muslim likewise
there are various wordings of
a and it's important that a person
learn one of these wordings you don't
have to know all of them and you don't
have to say all of them but you do have
to make sure you're saying at least one
of them right so you need to make sure
that the wording that you choose is a
wording that is authentically reported
from the prophet Prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam Scholars of Islam
mentioned that the supplications of
the Prophet s. wasam and
thear they are to be narrated and they
are to be worded exactly literally as
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
was narrated to have worded them and
that they not be altered or mentioned by
meaning generally the narrations of the
Prophet sallallah alai wasam what's
important in narration is their meaning
that when a person narrates them they
narrate them by the meaning even if the
wording slightly varies however when it
comes to wording ofar and supplications
the scholars of Islam
mention he says
[Silence]
now is still speaking about the first
tah and that is that this is the only
that he would make in the
first when a person sits for the first
of a prayer that has more than one so
other
than then he would
s say only this meaning the Dua the
supplication
of to the end of the
narration and that he Alam would make
this very brief meaning that this T is
not lengthy it is very brief and it has
not been authentically reported ever
that the prophet Sall wasam would make a
Salah upon himself in this situation
meaning what we refer to
as this is something which is reserved
for the
final and it is not something that is to
be done in the
first also the other things which are
particular to the final t such as
seeking refuge in Allah from four things
what are those four things seeking
refuge in Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala from
the punishment of the Grave from the
punishment of the here the Hellfire from
the misguides of this life and the
Hereafter from the
the fitna of or the trials and
tribulations
of this is something which is reserved
as well to the to the final T and those
Scholars that mention that this is to be
done and it's okay and it's must to be
done in the first this is something
which they have derived from
generalities that are found but we don't
have any specifics that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi was or his companions
would do it in this way hence these are
things which are reserved solely for the
second T the first T is just to have
the Dua the supplication of t in it as
we have just
mentioned and he
s after completing the first he would
stand
up to go and transition into the third
ra he would do this by shifting his
weight forward putting his two feet
up the balls of his feet onto the ground
planting them and then standing up while
having his weight and using his hands on
his thighs and his knees to stand up
this is
how describes this he
[Silence]
says
and in Muslim and in some wordings
in it's narrated that the prophet sallai
am would raise his hands in this
position so what does that mean that
means that when he has concluded his T
he would stand up and when he would
reach the standing position he would
raise his hands and then he would place
them right over left and then continue
to
recite it's mentioned that he would only
recite in the third fourth
of prayer and it has not been
authentically reported as tells us here
that he would recite anything in
addition
to in the third or
fourth of obligatory prayer so in the
second and third of second and third of
the third of the second the third and
fourth excuse me me the third and fourth
of and and and in the third
of he would recite
only he said and it was not something
that would be of the actions of the
Prophet Sall alai wasallam in prayer
that he would move his head around and
look around while he is in prayer and in
he was asked about someone who does this
during his or her prayer that you're in
prayer and you're looking
around and the prophet sallallahu
alaih wasallam responded and said this
is a a theft that the Shan committ
towards the prayer of a person because
if a person is is looking around at that
moment they have lost their focus in
prayer and if they have lost their focus
in prayer the only thing that they are
that they are achieving in their prayer
is what they have focused on and what
they have said whole heart whole
wholeheartedly and earnestly and so if a
person becomes distracted at any time
during that prayer they have essentially
lost that part of the prayer prayer and
so the prophet sallallahu alai
wasallam mentions that this is a type
of deprivation that a Shan performs
on a person's prayer that they will
steal parts that he the Shan will steal
parts of a a person's prayer and this is
one of the ways that that happens he
says well
can yet this doesn't mean that it is
totally impermissible for a person to
look at something while he is in prayer
if there is some thing that a person
that draws a person's attention and a
person needs to look at it during prayer
then this is something which is
permissible U let's say there's a loud
noise and people look towards where that
noise came from or the Imam is praying
in front of people and they're looking
at the Imam what he is doing what his
position is or anything else there's
some kind of something occurred for a
person to have to look towards that
thing this is something which
is which is permissible and this is
something which is
not a problem what we're speaking
about is being distracted on a constant
basis in
prayer he says
[Silence]
another thing is that a
person has a period where they can
supplicate or ask for anything during
this period and that is after a person
finishes
at
finishes finishes seeking Refuge from
four
things between this and Salam there is a
window there in which the prophet
sallallah alai
wasam would often use to make
supplication for certain things so
just as a person is in suud after he
finishes
sub
subh and wishes to make Dua for any
miscellaneous thing then likewise this
position where a person has finished his
of just before making
a this is a time when a person is to
also make Dua for whatever he or she
desires to make Dua for it is to that
person's discretion
this has been collected from the actions
of the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam and also from his words that he
mentioned make Dua during this time
and he had also been narrated to have
made Dua during that time as is in the
narration
of he commanded that and in the
of he actually did that as well
he
says and as for making Dua
supplication after a person makes tasim
after you make Salam to the right or to
the left you're finished with your
prayer you are now making tasim you
finish your tasim and stand there make
Dua either facing the during making this
Dua or as the IM he would finish
conclude then he would turn around and
face the people that he had just LED in
prayer and to make Dua during this
position this is not something that the
prophet sallallah alai wasallam ever was
narrated to have done in this
way he says
and ask for
Dua which have to do with prayer we
find that any Dua that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam usually
mentions most of them that have to do
with prayer they are in prayer during
prayer not after he says
[Silence]
he
says and this matches up with the
general spirits of
prayer that when a person is in
prayer essentially when a person is in
prayer he is in a state of
connectedness with Allah subhanahu wa
taala and so when a person makes Dua it
is during that ceremonious connectedness
but when a person breaks his Connection
by making T and exits the prayer this
now is an inferior time to make
Dua notice where I say an inferior time
meaning it is not the superior time to
make Dua the superior time to make Dua
would be during that connected period
when a person is still in prayer an
inferior time compared to the superior
time would be after a person breaks his
prayer and after a person has made T so
we see this often
that people
will be in prayer and they will be
making Salah after they finish the Salah
they make
a and then they will either do some kind
of or they will make Dua immediately
after and often times with raising the
hands
right if a person leads prayer he will
do it facing the with his back to the
people that he had just LED in prayer or
they will turn around and face the
people that they have just LED in prayer
and open their hands there's another one
that didn't mention and that is where
sometimes we see some imams they feel
reluctancy to turn their back towards
the right so they will turn halfway so
to the right is the people that they
just let in prayer to the left is the or
vice versa and then they will make Dua
in that position none of this is
something that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would do this is not of
the Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
Sunnah when we look at the pattern of
prayer we find that
supplication asking Allah is something
that occurs in prayer and remembrance of
Allah is something that occurs after
prayer
Allah subhanahu waala
mentions
in commanding the prophet sallallah
alaih wasallam and the companions that
which translates to and if you conclude
your prayer then remember
Allah standing sitting and on your sides
meaning in all positions remember Allah
subhana wa so we see that after the
conclusion of prayer this is a time
which is the remembrance of Allah is
appropriate during this time
supplication is appropriate during
prayer right because of the reason that
we have just
mentioned also this issue of
reluctancy to turn around we'll mention
this now may mention it later it escapes
me if he has or
not
when a person leads another in prayer
meaning they have a row of people behind
them they have people praying behind
them when the prophet s. wasam would
conclude
prayer he would turn around and face the
people that he had just LED in
prayer okay would he turn to the right
or would he turn to the left both both
are
narrated and in the narration of I
masud IB Mas mentions that
he would more often turn to the left
than he would to the
right and then he would face his
congregation the people he just LED in
prayer and his back would be towards the
right this is how the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would do it he would
turn around he would put his back
towards the he would face the people
that he had just led him prayer there is
nothing wrong with this there is nothing
to be reluctant about some people
feel a reluctancy to turn their back
towards the if you are in prayer n don't
turn your back towards the
obviously but outside of prayer this is
something which is perfectly
normal likewise people mention this
during
the position that they sit some
people even mention that you should do
this in your house you should turn your
bed so that your right side if you're
laying on your right side you're facing
towards the unless you are dead this is
not a position that you should
assume there's no narrations of the
Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam which
mentioned this or if a person is sitting
that they have their feet towards the
that this is somehow
impermissible this is not only
permissible but this is the way that
some of the companions who had
injuries to their feet or legs would
pray sitting on the floor with one or
both of their feet towards the there's
nothing wrong with this this is
something that people have conjured up
and it's something which comes from
ex excessive Zeal or or or we should say
unguided Zeal right because it's good to
have Zeal it's good to be enthusiastic
about following the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam but Zeal is is not
enough you have to be zealous and you
have to be guided you have to have
knowledge of what you're doing pure
emotion is not good for
anybody there is a
narration which some Scholars view is
authentic or at least
Hass that the best of positions to sit
are is a position that faces you towards
the the scholars of Islam mentioned that
this is during Dua but this doesn't have
anything to do with when a person sleep
excuse me when a person sleeps or when a
person sits
Etc likewise some of the F have
mentioned that when a person
Slaughters he should lay the animal on
the right side its right
side facing the and Slaughter it which
makes it very awkward for the majority
of humanity to slaughter because the
majority of
humanity is right-handed so if I lay the
animal on its right side its head is
here and its body is here and I have the
knife in my right hand it makes it
extremely awkward for me to slaughter
this is
conjecture some Scholars some of the fuk
mentioned this there is nothing explicit
from the prophet sallallahu alaih
wasallam that he would do this rather
slaughtering
of slaughtering of an
animal that is an animal that is laid on
its side hence goat or sheep they're the
only ones laid really I mean you can lay
a cow down but it's extremely
difficult and a camel is
impossible this is on its left side so
that the person can adequately reach
with the knife if he is
right-handed continues
on he
says and and this principle that we just
mentioned this pattern
of this pattern of
in prayer a person is to make
Dua outside of prayer a person is to
make when we see
narrations such as the narration of mub
jab oh mu the prophet alai wasallam said
to
[Silence]
there's a narration that the prophet
sallallahu alaih wasallam said to Mu I
do love you and I'd to teach you
something do not leave any prayer
that you pray except at the end of that
prayer you
say many of us know this narration the
scholars of Islam have differed has is
this before
or is this
after and the correct
opinion either way it's not a big issue
I mean as long as it is said it is
slightly vague and that is fine but what
is more in accordance with the pattern
of what we see in the Quran and Sunnah
of the placement of Supplication and the
placement of remembrance it would be
before T right based on what
has told us
here he
says when the prophet sallallah alaih
wasallam would
make he would say in this
wording just that he would say this
to the right and then he would say this
as well to the
left tells us that this is the prophet
sallallahu alam's custom this is what he
would always do most of the time right
[Silence]
says and it's also been
narrated that the prophet sallallahu
alai wasallam would only make one
t
right narrates this
in that he would make one
Tas straightforward
so he would
say and then he would turn his head
halfway between all the way right and
straight this is the wording
of says this narration is problematic in
its chain and its
authenticity yet even if we were to say
that this narration is authentic this is
something which would occur
in
during right and this is something that
he would do during not during regular
Salah with people praying behind
him there are a number of ways to make
t right that have been narrated that the
prophet s. was
did the way that he would most commonly
make is the way that we just described
how should this T
be well we are told how it should not
be and that is is it should not
be it should not be a fox moves its
head right very rapid and
jerky this is not the Sunnah of the
Prophet
Sall rather
narrates that the prophet
sallam would make
T and we would be able to see the
whiteness of his cheek if we were
praying behind
him
right so how is that he would turn all
the way because if you're sitting behind
me how are you going to see my cheek
unless I turn all the way right this is
how he would
make that is the proper way to make
whether you are leading prayer or you
are being led in prayer all
right there are other ways that he had
been narrated to have made
T right I'm going to mention them
but the way that he would make t
commonly is the way that mentioned here
with that
wording to both
sides the first is what what we just
mentioned that's number one number
two so we add bar to the
right a third is
to the
right to the left without to the left
right and this falls into a pattern and
that is
that
right then there is the fourth way that
he was narrated and that is the
narration of and that is
and then he would turn his head
slightly not completely to the right but
this is something that is only narrated
that he did
during one final note and that is that a
general rule in praying behind an
IM is the statement of the Prophet Sall
wasam that the Imam has been appointed
as the Imam that he should be followed
in
prayer so if the IM makes tasim in a
certain way you make that tasim exactly
as he did right so if the Imam
says to the right and one less to the
left then that is how you will make as
well person is to follow the Imam
whatever the Imam does as long as what
the does as part of the
Sunnah what do I mean by that well there
is a
narration that
mu was leading the companions in
prayer and because of an injury to his
leg when he would be in tah or the
sitting
position he would stick his leg out
right he would be sitting down on the
ground and one of his legs would be
facing towards
and so he noticed that everyone that
prayed behind him that day prayed in
that same way with their each person had
a foot sticking
out who told them this is
only and this is not to be taken
literally in every single thing that the
Imam does perhaps the Imam has an injury
perhaps the Imam is unaware whatever it
is a person follows the IM in what is of
the of the Prophet s.
wasam we will
conclude there for this evening
inshallah next week we will continue on
between 7 and
8:00 with
the the supplication that the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam would make
just before making tasim and then we
will move on to some of the things that
he would say after
after
making and then we will get into some of
the rulings of a